so one of my questions is you talk about
this culture between black and black
violence what is your solution then to
that don't commit crimes I mean my feel
like there's a I mean maybe my broader
solution really is that the is that
these communities require more police
not less there's a woman named Jane levy
who writes for the LA Times she's
actually on the left and she wrote an
entire book about how a lot of the
disparities in crime particularly black
communities were due to racism but not
in a way that we think of racism like
white cops going and beating people up
in black neighborhoods but because white
people basically said to black
neighborhoods take care of yourself
right if there's high violence in your
in your areas then you take care of it
yourself that leads to higher tribal
levels of violence in any society right
whenever there's not an enforcement
mechanism in place to actually stop
crime then the crime rates go up and in
fact you know the the broken windows
theory in New York City has saved an
enormous number of black lives because
the police were actually present and
active you need more active present
police hunting down people who kill
other people that's part of the problem
part of the problem is that you actually
need fathers who stick around this is
true in white communities and black
communities one of the great tragedies
of the last four decades in the United
States that the single motherhood rate
has risen not just in the black
community from 20 percent in 1960 to
over 70 percent now but in five percent
in the white community to over forty
percent now that's it's a huge jump in
both communities young men particularly
do need a male influence there to curb
them as a as a man who was once young I
can attest to this so I think that it is
yeah that's that's another aspect and
obviously once you actually lower the
crime rate then you're gonna get more
economic growth is what's happened in
particular areas of New York where once
the police were actually able to go in
and shut down crime in particular areas
and then suddenly businesses come back
in they weren't afraid of being robbed
and suddenly people were willing to live
in those areas who weren't willing to
live before this is gentrification and
gentrification is a good thing right the
left is opposed gentrification by
suggesting that oh it's people throwing
people out of their historic homes and
all this nonsense the fact is that if
the if the quality of life in an area
gets better not worse that seems to me
an undeniable good right so if the area
gets better that's gentrification if the
area stays crappy it's catalyzation I
mean there has to be some solution
you can't just claim that when things
get better that's racism when things get
worse that's racism also right so the
reason that New York City has gotten
better is because of increased policing
so increased policing a cultural focus
on fathers staying in the home
and and mothers not bearing children out
of wedlock and an individual commitment
not to commit crimes
so just following up real quick after
that so would you say the solution then
is to improve education in that sense
teaching these people early on to stop
doing these things I mean I honestly
don't think that the the quality of the
educational system is heavily connected
to crime just because I don't think that
schools are the folks who teach people
not to kill each other I think that's
usually your parents so I think that the
quality of schools is more a reflection
of the poverty of neighborhoods than it
is the cause of crime rates in
neighborhoods I think it's more of an
effect than a cause in other words